guys as I always say rest yourselves
you've got a lot of work to do well
welcome to the White House it is truly a
pleasure to be here with all of you
today for the first ever White House
convening on food marketing to children
but before we get started I just wanted
to take a moment to express my sincere
heartbreak over Monday's tragedy at the
Navy Yard here in Washington the men and
women who lost their lives devoted their
careers to protecting our country and as
we mourn those that we lost and we pray
for those who were injured we also honor
their service and we hold all of their
loved ones in our hearts at this very
difficult time
so with that we're going to put you to
work thank you again for being here
I want to start by thanking stam for
that very kind introduction but more
importantly for all the work that he and
his team have done to make Let's Move a
reality and I want to thank all of you
for joining us today all of you in this
room you come to this issue from all
different angles you're experts
advocates parents you represent food and
beverage companies media and
entertainment companies and so much more
and we're eager to have a lively and
constructive dialogue with you about how
we market food to our children we're
eager to hear more from everyone in this
room about what's working where we're
falling short and how we can keep moving
forward together on this complex and
challenging but very important issue and
I think it's important to note that
we're having this conversation in the
midst of what I believe is a cultural
shift that is happening in this country
a transformation and how we live and eat
that many of us could never have
imagined even just a few years ago I see
it everywhere I go all across this
country I see it in chain restaurants
that are serving kale salads and they're
filling kids menus with not just nuggets
and fries but with broccoli and
whole-wheat pasta I see it in churches
where instead of fried chicken and mac
and cheese for church supper they're
serving up grilled fish and brown rice I
see it online where parenting cooking
and health blogs are crammed with
healthy recipes and tips about providing
better nutrition for our kids and I see
it in schools where students can't wait
to tell me about their new salad bar or
how they ate a radish or tried
cauliflower for the first time and
actually liked it in fact we recently
sponsored a recipe contest for kids here
at the White House and we got over 1,300
entries from 50 states across the
country and I can't tell you how many of
those recipes featured quinoa well
figure and if all of this doesn't
provide sufficient evidence of an
important shift then just take a look at
the market research the National
Restaurant Association surveyed chefs
about trends in their industry and three
of the top 10 trends were specifically
about healthy kids meals a survey by the
food Marketing Institute found that 90%
of grocery stores are offering healthy
recipes to their customers and 98% of
them maintain health and wellness
websites and today for the first time in
decades we're actually starting to move
the needle on this issue between 2008
and 2011 obesity rates among low-income
preschoolers dropped in 19 states and
territories across the country and
childhood obesity rates are falling in
cities like New York and Philadelphia
and in states like California and
Mississippi but while we have made
important progress when one in three
kids is still on track to develop
diabetes and when diet has now surpassed
smoking as the number one risk factor
for disease and death in this country
then we clearly have much more work to
do
and yes we have made meaningful changes
in a number of areas by getting
healthier food into our schools and
communities but at the end of the day if
we truly want to solve this problem we
also need to get our kids to actually
want to eat these healthier options and
I say this not just as a first lady
who's been working on this issue for the
past three and a half years I say this
as a mom who has been working hard to
raise two girls as you know I haven't
always lived in the White House not so
long ago I was a busy working mom
desperate to find quick affordable meals
and snacks for my family I needed cereal
that my girls could pour themselves I
needed lunches I could pack in a hurry I
needed juice boxes that my
three-year-old could hold in her hand in
the back seat of my car I needed dinners
that came precooked and ready to pop in
the microwave and most importantly I
needed my kids to actually eat all of
this food I was buying for them and all
of you in the food and beverage industry
delivered for me you manufactured and
sold the convenience foods I needed and
you did a brilliant job making those
foods something my kids would want so
when I opened those boxes and bags my
girls were happy and I was happy problem
solved but then like a lot of moms I
started learning more about nutrition
and health I started reading labels
I started getting warnings from my
pediatrician about the health of my kids
and I began to realize that some of
these foods that were so quick and cheap
and tasty weren't always healthy for my
kids so once again moms like me turn to
your industry for help but this time we
didn't just want the foods to be
convenient and affordable we wanted them
to be good for our kids as well and once
again many of you have started to
deliver by manufacturing some of the
healthier options and and that is an
important first step
but once again moms like me are relying
on all of you to actually help our kids
get excited about eating that food and
that's why I wanted to bring all youth
together today because you guys know
better than anyone how to get kids
excited you've done it before and we
need you to do it again and fortunately
you have everything it takes to get this
done because through the magic of
marketing and advertising all of you
more than anyone else have the power to
shape our kids tastes and desires you
all know that our kids are like little
sponges they absorb whatever is around
them but they don't yet have the ability
to question and analyze what they're
told
instead they believe just about
everything they see and hear especially
if it's on TV and when the average child
is now spending nearly eight hours a day
in front of some kind of screen many of
their opinions and preferences are being
shaped by the marketing campaigns you
all create and that's where the problem
comes in you see the average child
watches thousands of food advertisements
each year and 86% of these ads are for
products loaded with sugar fat salt by
contrast our kids see an average of just
one ad a week for healthy products like
water or fruits and vegetables just one
ad a week
and as you all know these ads work kids
who see food advertised on TV are
significantly more likely to ask for
them at the store a phenomenon known as
pester power new to me
sounds right though and research shows
that a child's first request for a
product happens as early as 24 months
and 75% of the time this request takes
place in a grocery store and given what
our kids are seeing on TV it should come
as no surprise what they're asking for
one study revealed that 45% of kids food
requests for things like cookies and
candy burgers fries and chips but just
three percent were for fruits and
vegetables so from the time our kids are
still in diapers we as parents are
already fighting an uphill battle to get
them interested in the foods that will
actually nourish them and help them grow
now like many parents Barack and I do
our best to limit our daughter's TV time
but as you all know these ads aren't
just on TV they're on the internet video
games smartphones billboards they're in
schools and store the displays they're
everywhere
and parents just can't keep up no matter
how hard we try so whatever we all might
believe about personal responsibility
and self-determination I think we can
agree that it doesn't necessarily apply
to children I think that we can all
agree that parents deserve more control
over the products and messages their
kids are exposed to and that's why I was
so pleased that 17 major American
companies came together on their own as
part of the children's food and beverage
advertising initiative to adopt new
standards for marketing to kids and I
know this wasn't easy forging consensus
among fierce competitors is a challenge
to say the least but these new standards
are beginning to have an impact and I
commend all of these companies for
taking action but of course while
limiting the marketing of
unhealthy food is critical it's not
enough we also need companies to
actually market healthy foods to kids
foods that have real nutritional value
foods that are fortified with real
fruits and vegetables whole grains and
low-fat dairy now I say this mindful
that companies serve exists to make a
profit and they need that in order to
survive and those profits keep our
economy going every day
but the fact is that marketing
nutritious foods to our kids isn't just
good for our kids health it can also be
good for companies bottom lines for
example the folks at bird's eye
vegetables launched a major marketing
campaign featuring characters from the
popular kids show iCarly
and their sales jumped 20 percent in
just two months Vidalia Onion did a
campaign with Shrek one of my favorites
and their sales went up 50% so I'm
confident that you all can sell healthy
foods to our kids and remain competitive
and profitable that's why some of your
company's marketers are playing a key
role in a new campaign to inspire people
in this country to drink more water you
see we know that water is such an
important component to good health but
so many other beverages have millions of
marketing dollars behind them that water
often gets drowned out that's why last
week we launched the new drink up
campaign a campaign to bring attention
to water as a healthy choice so that
when people are thirsty they reach for a
glass of water so I say this because
when it comes to believing in the power
of marketing to promote healthy choices
to our kids I'm not just talking the
talk I'm actually walking the walk on
this one but so far I've spent a lot of
time talking about food and beverage
companies but those of you from media
companies also play a critical role in
marketing
to our children and I want to call on
all of you to do your part as well that
means for example limiting the use of
your licensed characters to market
unhealthy food to kids and limiting
unhealthy food ads in your programming
Disney has pledged to do just that and I
know that other media companies can
follow suit but I'm also asking you to
actually use your licensed characters to
promote healthy food Sesame Street has
been doing this for years which is why
when parents turn on Sesame Street or
the Disney Channel they know and trust
that their kids won't be bombarded with
messages promoting unhealthy food and
that trust is valuable that trust is
good for your businesses that's why so
many of you in the private sector are
leading the way on this issue you are
innovating you're taking risks you're
serving as models for your industries
and it's starting to make a difference
not just for our kids but for your
shareholders as well and I'm here today
with one simple request and that is to
do even more and move even faster to
market responsibly to our kids now I
want to be clear about what I'm asking
here I am not asking anyone to take the
fun out of childhood as we all know
treats are one of the best parts of
being a kid instead the goal here is to
empower parents instead of undermining
them as they try to make healthier
choices for their families and we need
you to lead the way in cream creating
demand for healthy food so that kids
actually start pestering us for those
foods in the grocery store and then
parents actually start buying them and
then companies have incentives to make
and sell even more
those foods and ideally in a decade or
so we would see a dramatic shift across
the entire industry we'd see companies
shifting marketing dollars away from
those less healthy products and
investing those dollars in your
healthier products instead that's how we
can make healthy eating a way of life
for our kids and for our families and
make no mistake about it meeting these
goals isn't just the right decision for
the short or medium term it can affect
your businesses for decades to come
see the decisions that you make about
marketing won't just affect what our
kids are eating today those decisions
are going to also affect the health of
your workforce tomorrow businesses are
losing 37 billion dollars a year due to
absenteeism lost productivity and health
care costs associated with obesity
related conditions and just imagine what
that number will look like in 20 years
from now if we stand by and let today's
unhealthy kids grow into unhealthy
adults who become the employees of
tomorrow and there's another long-term
factor that's also worth considering and
that is the potential trend in our kids
food preferences and tastes you see over
the past few years we've seen some real
changes in the foods our kids are eating
starting from the time they're born for
example changes in the women infants and
children's program are helping millions
of women across America buy healthier
products for their kids and 10,000 child
care centers across the country have
committed to serving more nutritious
food as part of Let's Move childcare in
addition we have implemented sweeping
changes in America's school lunch
programs such that nearly 32 million
children across the country are now
eating more fruits and vegetables whole
grains and and other healthy food every
day and starting next year school
vending machines will be stocked with
healthy items as well so healthier
eating is starting to become the new
norm for our kids this is what they're
getting used to
and for many this is all they'll ever
know and as their palates and their
habits adjust that could have a serious
effect on their tastes and preferences
not just as children but for the rest of
their lives it could even affect what
they ultimately buy and serve their own
children in the future so this isn't
just some passing trend or fad so there
might be those out there whose strategy
is to just wait this out folks who might
still be thinking in themselves well in
a few years this lady will be gone and
this whole let's move thing will finally
be over so we can go back to business as
usual and I know that none of you here
were thinking that way but if you know
anyone who is you might want to remind
them that I didn't create this issue and
it's not gonna go away three and a half
years from now when I'm no longer first
lady this issue has truly taken on a
life of its own because it is affecting
just about every family and every
community in this country parents are
increasingly anxious as they see their
kids developing diabetes high
cholesterol high blood pressure
conditions that would have been
unthinkable to find in children just a
generation ago there are now 79 million
pre-diabetics in this country many of
them young adults and we're even seeing
people in their 20s and 30s having heart
attacks and strokes so I have yet to
meet a single parent who doesn't
understand the threat of obesity to
their health and to their children's
health and they are looking for
solutions they're starting to think
about how they feed themselves and their
families and you all can take advantage
of this you can get ahead of the curve
you have everything it takes right now
to seize this societal challenge as an
unprecedented business opportunity right
now your company is employs some of the
most brilliant creative innovate
mine's in the entire country and you all
can sell just about anything to our kids
and if anyone can get our kids to eat
their vegetables it's all of you and I
know it won't be easy I know you might
have to take some short-term risks to
get a long-term payoff but that's what
great American companies do they act
boldly they innovate they take risks and
remember it wasn't that long ago that
going green or taking your business
online were considered risky endeavors
but throughout our history the companies
that saw where the future was headed and
took that leap have been rewarded and I
want you to know that I will do
everything in my power to celebrate and
highlight this kind of leadership on
behalf of our kids that's what I've been
doing since I first started working on
this issue whether it was visiting a
Walmart stocked with fresh produce or
having dinner at an Olive Garden with a
healthier kids menu or hanging out with
Mickey to celebrate Disney's
achievements on this issue and I am
eager to have these same kinds of
celebrations with every company in this
room so I hope that all of you will
really engage I hope that you'll really
talk to each other and learn from each
other and come up with new solutions
that will make a real difference for our
kids
we want to hear from everyone involved
in this issue from industry leaders to
advocates to researchers and to parents
because we're all in this together and
while I know I've been talking a lot
about corporate America's
responsibilities on this issue the
advocates and experts here have an
important responsibility to your words
matter
you all can help either provide
incentives to change or you can be
barriers to change so we need you to be
constructive in your criticisms and
strategic in your calls to action
because when it comes to marketing it
can be hard for companies to take risks
they face pressures from Wall Street
there are also limits to how fast they
can move and how far they can go before
they start losing custody
so when companies do step up and take
risks we need to be supportive even if
we think they haven't gone far enough we
need to help them make those risks pay
off so that they'll go even farther and
so that other companies will follow
their lead and as for those of you in
the private sector I hope that you will
head back to your companies ready to
think big and act boldly on behalf of
our kids because while running a
profitable business is important I know
that you all aren't just business
executives you all are also good
neighbors and good citizens and proud
parents and grandparents many of you
didn't go into business just to make
money but to problem-solve and make
people's lives better you went into
business to create great American
products and build great American
institutions and to leave a legacy that
your kids and grandkids will inherit
with pride and in the end that's what
let's move is all about it's about the
legacy we're leaving for the next
generation and for generations to come
and standing here today with all of you
people who represent some of the most
visionary pioneering companies and
organizations in this country I have
never felt more confident about our
children's future and of course the
future of this country so I look forward
to hearing about what you all come up
with today and I look forward to
celebrating new commitments and
achievements in the months and years
ahead
thank you all god bless you good luck
and work hard
you